don't quit too soon here's the quote
many assume that half efforts can be
effective a small jump is easier than a
large one but no one wishing to cross a
wide ditch would cross half of it first
I'm convinced that the majority of
content creators that start a YouTube
channel start to feel discouraged and
then give up they quit too soon and they
give up too easily the truth is it takes
a lot of energy time persistence and
consistency to ultimately reach escape
velocity to ultimately build momentum on
YouTube and the problem with halfway
efforts is exactly what the quote said
it's like trying to jump over an entire
ditch but only giving it a halfway
effort where you're gonna fall in the
middle you're going to get stuck in the
slump and so of course there's a time to
quit there is a time to Pivot your
channel we actually have a dedicated
think media podcast episode about that
that I'll link up in the show notes if
you've given it adequate time adequate
uploads adequate energy adequate
strategy and it's not working yet yet
then maybe you should give up but I'm
certain that 99 of people have not done
the former things that I've mentioned
the key here is don't quit too soon two
things number one I've had too much
coffee today number two if you have not
seen our free master class yet you're
gonna love it if you're serious about
growing your YouTube channel just go to
thinkmasterclass.com for a one hour Deep
dive on-demand YouTube strategy class
it's sick and uh I'm gonna go refill my
coffee hope to see you on the class